[Musik]
äußerlich sieht man ihnen nichts an
erst im umgang lässt es sich
schrittweise herausspielen es heißt bill
gates und steven spielberg haben es auch
mozart einstein und der künstler andy
warhol seines gehabt haben diese
menschen hier haben es sicher
das asperger-syndrom
großes
puzzle mit ganz vielen einzelnen teile
wenn ich am morgen aufstehen denn ich
wollte jetzt mal anders also ich muss
euch immer wieder von neuem und alles
zusammen
sie alle arbeiten in stäfa am zürichsee
in der firma asperger informatik
[Musik]
raser muss mit einem wortschatz mozart
musik das hat die wenigsten
in dieser firma hier können sie ihre
spezielle wahrnehmen und art zu denken
gewinnbringend einsetzen sie sind
zuverlässig systematisch und hoch
konzentrationsfähigkeit
führt wird die firma von einer frau
chefin susan konzern hat einen
überdurchschnittlichen iq die 41 jährige
stellt bewusst nur asperger ein
bewerbungsschreiben und zeugnisse sind
versuchen in ihrem betrieb nicht
entscheiden
wer mitarbeiter
stört mich also ist das nicht meine
projekt in seiner quartal mit dem
mittagessen
die firma macht webdesign und testet
software für asperger ist es wichtig
ihre aufmerksamkeit bündeln zu können
der bildschirm eignet sich gut dafür
schwierig wird es wenn mehrere dinge
gleichzeitig ausgeführt werden müssen
was man nicht so hart sind so siebziger
teamsitzungen
sunrise praktisch mit wiso infos
für euch oder in den ruhestand sondern
vor allem
sehr anstrengend für mich
es gespräche in der gruppe und mir dann
so viel aufmerksamkeit
ruf verwandelt
klose und richtig reagieren dass man den
inhalt gar
nicht wirklich mit dem berühmt und das
sind am nachfolger
unerschöpflich jedoch ist die freude der
mitarbeiter an den hunden der chefin sie
schätzen es dass sich tiere besser ihren
bedürfnissen anpassen können als
menschen
die vierbeiner sind fast immer in süßen
snack
bahnhofplatz kann aufgeplatzt
nicht nur opel
frage ist fördert man durch so etwas
nicht die
die unkontrollierte zucht von hunden
hier in der schweiz
asperger nehmen fast alles wörtlich
reagieren deshalb sehr sachbezogen auch
bei emotionalen team
im reizarmen rahmen kann der schüchtern
wirkende mike seine stärken einbringen
wie hier beim lernen einer neuen
programmiersprache
[Musik]
er hat extrem geduld und ausdauer machen
in der krippe sky und dann lernt das und
er lernt es richtig glatt läuft super
konzentriert sich nicht ablenken und
nachher hornist einer weg
auch cassidy ist meisterin im
fokussieren
außerhalb ihrer familie spricht sie
wenig ihre stärke liegt im visuellen
bezeichnen
cassidy liebt manga-comics nutzt hier
eher talent für mitarbeiter porträts
kreiert grafiken innerhalb weniger
minuten
sie kann einfach so in den kopf ich kann
einfach visuell darstellen dass wir
nicht mehr gekühlt und
sohn sowie zeigt
was alles im kopf ist schade und ich
sehe auch voller wilder
es kommt war sekunden neues den
cassidys schwäche ist das telefonieren
spontan auf fragen zu antworten kostet
sie riesige überwindung
nächste ausbildung am arbeitsplatz
bietet susan den beiden lehrlingen auch
hilfe an und sich im alltag
zurechtzufinden
was für andere ein einfacher gang zur
post ist um einen brief aufzugeben wird
für die beiden in vielerlei hinsicht zur
großen herausforderung
asperger können eindrücke nicht filtern
gleichzeitig überall passen teile aber
keinen überblick
dann unter ihnen setzt sich haben also
erst die nummer
mit dem minuten dann buchstaben die wahl
musste halt hat und hat gleichzeitig im
kopf was die staffeln statt
was muss ich machen muss
darf sich gar nicht dass unicef
werbung beim ticket knopf verwirrt
und das schon ab gerade aus filz will
und dann geht sie so ein blog carta
verblieb ein star man weiß nicht was
machen
überall faden und hinweise die nichts
mit dem auftrag der post zu tun haben
nämlich etwas von a nach b zu bringen
eigentlich wissen dass er auch bei einer
blockade fremde leute um hilfe fragen
könnte
es mir danken
ich tue alles plant als ich und ich bin
so wie in
mindenerwald du am meisten zum bordell
usa
und nimmt eigentlich verschnitt war
außer gott die nächste 12 schritt
wirklich sicher fühle mich erstaunt war
der ablauf für die verschiedenen
varianten wirklich es hat so lange immer
noch ist offen ob es unvorhergesehenes
kongo fühlt sich noch nicht ganz sicher
und
das unerwartete passiert
das schlachtgewicht von lehrern
michaels analytische und systematischer
denkweise ist beim programmieren ein
großer vorteil sein perfektionsdrang
erschwert jedoch sein sozialleben
vermeintlich fehler kann er nur schwer
ertragen
ganz triviale viele also fehler im
zwischenmenschlichen zusammenleben wenn
ich mich irgendwie dumm verhalten weil
ich irgendetwas nicht verstehe dass es
bei mir eben durchaus so dass ich
vielleicht nicht ironie aber durchaus
irgendwelche anderen dinge nicht so
richtig verstehe die anderen menschen
und
gerade auf gesichtsausdrücke nicht so
reagieren kann wie es vielleicht
gewünscht ist vom gegenüber das heißt
ich kann die mimik eines menschen nicht
so gut lesen und war deshalb ein
feedback in worten und
ja das ist schon etwas schwierig
teilweise
während der arbeit muss sich susan immer
wieder kurz zurückziehen die geringste
nervosität blockiert sie oft geht dann
gar nichts mehr
aber vor habe ich mir keinen sport mehr
physische nähe ist schwierig versuchen
darf geht dann einfach so er körperlich
die spannung
und
fluchtgedanken will weg und das macht er
intuitiv im gespräch war über grund ist
so richtig packt bin gerührt sie sagen
und anzieht und im loslassen
gar nicht
zugelassen weil sich die attacke und
heftig mir nicht entziehen
die wahrnehmung von us bürgern ist nicht
veränderbar doch das sozialverhalten
kann jederzeit verbessert werden
dass ich eigentlich
an jener pro vorhaben will ich einfach
nicht grüßt
will die blockade und dann stand die
großen oder sogar ausgesprochen können
für mich da und bist gefragt mach die
schwarze nacht auf dann nehme ich halt
bis gefragt da bin ich auch einen
antwort
ist der hauptgang
das ist auch so unangenehme situationen
und das habe ich dann überwunden indem
ich das einfach
drüber so internetportal dann einfach
drüber nicht lang jede woche drei dates
aufgemacht und aufgang gegangen ist mit
das schlimmste ist immer besser sagte
susan spürt schon als kind ihre
andersartigkeit leidet aber nicht
darunter denn ihr vater und fast alle
geschwister sind auch asperger
schon früh faszinieren sie mathematisch
beschreibbare informationen als
wirtschaftsinformatikerin bringt sie es
bis zur geschäftsleitung mit 35 gründet
sie ihre eigene firma
[Musik]
arbeitsweg und außen reize sind eine
große belastung von neun monaten hat
susan deshalb firmensitz und wohnungen
zusammengelegt gewiss die sache aber ich
kann so unbekannt sind
die erlöse auf stoß und dann ganz lang
für mich hieß es nur einander scout und
der notar ist zufall
jetzt kann sie die anmeldung der firma
in stäfa nicht länger hinauszögern
susan steht unter großem druck obwohl
sie sich nichts anmerken lässt auf dem
weg zum notar lenkt sie sich ab mit
einer anekdote
gemacht dass man zwei stunden
und auf zwei stopps
gemacht
dieser baum
in der nähe der bank befindet sich auch
das notariat
ada
wunder
susan hat ihre unterlagen vorher
eingeschickt dennoch ist der amtsbesuch
für sie eine beunruhigende reise ins
ungewisse immer schwingt die angst mit
auf ungewohnte situationen nicht richtig
reagieren zu können
revision vor der us-bürger im format die
kranke mittelstadt umgeknickt und hat
die arbeit mit urkunde und
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das polizei
legal
polizei
dann etwas passiert einfach illegal für
ihrem mann stefan
unterdessen vertieft an erhielt er mit
roche ihr mathematisches wissen
logik liegt asperger von dieser milden
form von autismus ist in der schweiz
etwa jeder tausendste betroffen
sachlicher informationsaustausch
bestimmt die kommunikation der beiden
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich die
bausparkasse drogen oder senat ist diese
störung abbas ich relativ frei wenn er
nach oder sie das motto godard oder so
macht ist das für einen theater spielen
das musste sich ereignet das man lernen
muss sich zwingend zu machen die für die
nun natürlich stört stört die
produktivität
der unverblümte direkte sprache das ist
für asperger auch in beziehungen
unerlässlich
da heißt
sehr schönes land
dann hat das zeug sich nicht gut
ich bin ein anderes sehr schätze sagte
neuer im tor gestanden ist und wir auf
dem glückscode sozusagen für ehrlichkeit
und
ja und wie manche maschinen die geburt
und werde dann du league oder verletzt
pascal konzer ist susan sex man
gelegentlich konnte zu besuch und
spaziert mit den hunden susan und er
sind freunde geblieben
eine beziehung mit einem us berger ist
versuchen unvorstellbar an nicht
autisten oder wie sie sagt neuroth
typischen schätzt susan vor allem eines
mehr oder weniger fähig ist und sich
meine
wünsche nach nähe und distanz
pascal musst du in einigen zurücksteckte
als nebenberuflicher dj war zu hause
beispielsweise oft gezwungen auf musik
zu verzichten weil die unruhige umgebung
versuchen schnell stress bedeutet
aber war seine beziehung mit suchen
sonst anders als mit jemanden ohne
asperger und wenn ja inwiefern
die
das ist großes bedürfnis zu untersuchen
dieser berücksichtigt
es gibt
dir ein
attribut
[Musik]
ja so was auch mit häuser
sind komisch kunden halten und sie ist
ein teil der mitarbeiter
ist normal nicht gewohnt aber das halb
traumblick geführt dass ich
habe der familie
nach fünf jahren sind die differenzen
doch zu groß geworden sowas ist
vielleicht weniger und weniger unter
nachbarn hat das wenig spontan bin dann
das ständig dass er reich und christina
das
unternehmen vor einer woche forderung
ist normal und dann doch irgendwann ist
wurde
dann haben unter beklagt habe
gemeinsamen erlebnis
das asperger syndrom ist eine angeborene
entwicklungsstörung
für susan ist es weder krankheit noch
schweres schicksal die diagnose war eine
erleichterung hat dir geholfen ihr
anderssein zu verstehen sich selbst zu
finden
sie pflegt einen natürlichen umgang
damit
sechs aus berka syndrom seien komme
dieser sache wir ja mal total irre bis
oder der gurt war willi schubladen
stecken dort
und
ich finde es übertrieben
und eigentlich ist zeigt das war ich
dass er überhaupt mitbewerb der
sehbehinderte oder blinde wo seitens
apple im zeitraum
schnell
in susan konzers firma können menschen
mit asperger ihre herausragenden
visuellen und analytischen stärken
nutzen und fördern
andersartigkeit ist hier kein hindernis
sondern eine chance
[Musik]